You may have noticed this week that
your gas prices have gone up.
I want to talk to you a little bit
about why a lot of it has to
do with Vladimir Putin.
The White House is trying to blame
record high gas prices on Russian
President Vladimir Putin and
the invasion of Ukraine.
Defending freedom is going to cost.
It's going to cost us as well
in the United States.
Facing collapsing approval ratings.
Democratic lawmakers are echoing
the same argument.
New York Congressman Gregory Meeks
announced that Americans should be
happy to make that kind of sacrifice
because in the long run, democracy
is at stake.
Even simpatico comedians are
pushing the idea that gas prices
are setting new highs because of
world events
Since the invasion, oil prices have
skyrocketed today.
The average gas price in America
hit an all time record high of over
$4 per gallon.
OK, that stings, but
a clean conscience is worth
a buck or two.
I'm willing to pay.
Important.
It's important I'm willing to pay
four dollars a gallon.
Hell, I'll pay fifteen dollars
a gallon because I drive a Tesla.
The sanctions that the U.S.
and most of Europe have levied
against Russia, one of the world's
largest oil producers were
of course, going to spook energy
markets. But the so-called Putin
price hike actually started
over a year ago.
Biden can't pin our eight percent
across the board inflation rate, the
likes of which was last seen early
in Ronald Reagan's first term,
entirely on Putin.
The main culprit is the massive
infusion of money into the economy
by the federal government and the
Federal Reserve.
Spending in Washington alone
increased 50 percent between 2019
and 2021.
On both Biden's and Donald Trump's
watch, it's a surefire way
to boost the cost of everything
as more dollars chase basically
the same amount of goods.
And when it comes to energy.
Specifically, the Biden
administration has pursued a number
of policies designed to make it more
expensive to produce fossil fuel
energy in an effort to reach a goal
of net zero carbon emissions
by 2050.
In fact, environmentalists cheered
Biden's bold move a week
into his presidency as the most
remarkable day in the history
of America's official response to
the climate crisis.
They said it marked the official
beginning of the end of the fossil
fuel era.
Biden's measures have included
halting new permits for drilling and
leases on federal lands, shutting
down the planned Keystone XL
pipeline and proposing the end
of tax credits for new drilling and
exploration projects.
He's been joined by congressional
Democrats have been working to
tighten regulations loosened during
the Trump years and otherwise
clamped down on oil producers.
At the state level, they
banned fracking in New York in 2014,
and California has effectively
stopped the practice in anticipation
of a 2024 ban.
Even when such moves have been
overturned by courts are only affect
future operations, Biden
and the Democrats have sent a loud
and clear signal that the future
will be green, even
if renewable sources aren't up to
the task of supplying our energy
needs. Currently, less than 13
percent of our energy comes from
renewable sources, and even as wind,
solar, hydroelectric and other
sustainable sources do get cheaper
and more reliable, we're a long
way from independance on fossil
fuels.
If patriotism is the last refuge
of a scoundrel, Biden is blaming
Putin for the predictable results
of his and Trump's irresponsible
policies.
If we can't expect lower fuel
prices, we can at least demand
an honest accounting of this most
insidious form of taxation.
Printing money to pay for federal
largesse with the bill coming
due at the gas pump, the grocery
store and just about
everywhere else.